[Musik]
dies kann da ja hat viele gesichter und
schubladen denken mag er wieder in der
musik noch im leben der berliner mit
indonesischen wurzeln ist ein ausnahme
geiger der immer wieder auch abseits der
klassik nach inspirationen sucht aber so
extravagant er auch wirkt für ihn zählt
allein die musik
[Applaus]
[Musik]
letztlich machen wir musik für leute
berühren wollen weil wir sie bewegen
wollen und weil wir in uns einen punkt
erreichen wollen wo wir selber so
berührt sind auf der bühne dass wir die
anderen auch damit bewegen können anders
geht's nicht
indonesien die heimat seiner eltern
besucht iskandar widjaja regelmäßig hier
ist der 32-jährige ein star
auftritte in david clips und tv-shows
haben ihn in dem asiatischen inselstaat
berühmt gemacht hier spielt er in den
großen konzerthäusern wie im vergangenen
jahr in jakarta bei dieser benefiz gala
für tsunami-opfer ich habe eine zeit
lang versucht obst an indonesien klassik
künstler in deutschland und seit ein
zwei jahren habe titel entschieden es
gibt nicht nur noch als gesamtpaket auch
wenn ich in indonesien mit spiele
und für für den präsidenten spiele
versuche ich immer mir selbst treu zu
bleiben und so so authentisch wie
möglich zu bekommen
[Musik]
auftritt in einem kölner club hier
spielt die skandia ja nicht nur
klassische musik das programm reicht von
johann sebastian bach bis zu einer
coverversion des hits schein der lehrer
von popstars hier
[Musik]
wir sprechen plötzlich stücke an und da
unterscheide ich eben nicht ist dass
jetzt dieses oder dazu noch und genau
das möchte ich auch in meinen konzerten
erreichen
ich möchte diese unterteilung aufbrechen
ich möchte dass leute die in meinem
konzert kommen wissen es gibt alles
[Musik]
so wie er in seiner musik ganz
unterschiedliche sachen probiert spielt
iskandarija ja auch gerne mit
verschiedenen images nicht nur bei
fotoaufnahmen
[Musik]
ich ziehe auf der bühne gerne outfits an
die irgendwie meinen
interpretationsansatz unterstreichen
und das kann wirklich sehr variieren von
extrem schlicht einfarbig nur in schwarz
total reduziert auf total erwartet
obwohl genau das ist das was mich auch
an der musik interessiert mit vier
jahren beginnt iskandar widjaja geige zu
spielen inspiriert von seinem großvater
einem komponisten nach einem geigen
studium in berlin hat er keine lust auf
die üblichen wettbewerber er spielt
lieber direkt bei weltklasse dirigenten
wie zubin mehta vor und überzeugt
demo aufnahmen für das nächste album
darauf soll es einen bunten stilmix
geben unter anderem experimentieren die
musiker mit einem stück des
italienischen barockkomponisten pedro
antonio locatelli
[Musik]
es kann david in indonesien ein star in
vielen welten zu hause
[Musik]